>>> SO A HUGE NEW DEAL THIS
MORNING AND A SURPRISE AT THAT.
THIS IS BETWEEN SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER CHUCK SCHUMER AND WEST
VIRGINIA DEMOCRATIC SENATOR JOE
MANCHIN.
THIS IS A MAJOR PIECE OF
LEGISLATION, ONE THAT THEY SAY
WOULD PAY DOWN THE NATIONAL
DEBT, CUT HEALTH CARE COSTS,
FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE AND BATTLE
INFLATION.
JOINING US NOW IS SOMEONE WHO
MAY HAVE BEEN A KEY PLAYER IN
MAKING THIS HAPPEN ACCORDING TO
THE "WASHINGTON POST," FORMER
TREASURY SECRETARY UNDER BILL
CLINTON LAWRENCE SUMMERS.
HE ALSO SERVED AS DIRECTOR OF
THE WHITE HOUSE ECONOMIC COUNCIL
IN THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH US
THIS MORNING.
THE "POST" REPORTS YOU HAD A
PRETTY IMPORTANT PHONE CALL WITH
JOE MANCHIN.
TALK TO US ABOUT YOUR ROLE HERE.
>> OH, I TALKED TO OFFICIALS
FROM -- FAIRLY FREQUENTLY FROM
TIME TO TIME, BUT IN ORDER TO DO
THAT I NEVER TALK ABOUT THE
CONFIDENTIAL CONVERSATIONS THAT
I HAVE, BUT THIS IS A GOOD BILL.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD ON INFLATION, WHICH HAS
BEEN MY PREOCCUPATION THIS LAST
YEAR, IT'S HISTORIC ON THE
ENVIRONMENT, IT'S GOING TO MAKE
OUR SOCIETY MORE FAIR AND EQUAL
AT LONG LAST, GETTING RID OF THE
CARRIED INTEREST LOOPHOLE, IT'S
GOING TO TAKE IMPORTANT STEPS
FORWARD ON ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
AND IT'S GOING TO INVEST IN THE
FUTURE OF OUR COUNTRY.
SO THIS IS A VERY STRONG BILL
AND I'M JUST DELIGHTED TO SEE
THIS AGREEMENT AND I HOPE IT ALL
MOVES FORWARD AS EXPEDITIOUSLY
AS POSSIBLE.
>> I UNDERSTAND YOU DON'T WANT
TO TELL US THE DETAILS OF YOUR
CONVERSATION WITH JOE MANCHIN SO
LET'S HAVE A CONVERSATION
BETWEEN YOU AND ME, I'M JOHN
BERMAN, I'M ASKING YOU,
SECRETARY SUMMERS, I'M CONCERNED
THAT THIS BILL MIGHT BE
INFLATIONARY, THAT YOU'RE
RAISING TAXES ON CORPORATIONS,
THAT YOU'RE SPENDING MONEY ON
CLIMATE CHANGE.
HOW WOULD YOU ALLAY THOSE
CONCERNS?
>> SO, JOHN, FIRST, THIS REDUCES
BUDGET DEFICITS AND SO BY
REDUCING BUDGET DEFICIT IT
REDUCES THE LEVEL OF DEMAND IN
THE ECONOMY.
SECOND, THIS REDUCES PRICES
DIRECTLY BY GOING AFTER
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AND GETTING
LOWER PRICES AND A BETTER DEAL
FOR TAXPAYERS WHEN THEY PURCHASE
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
THIRD, THIS INCREASES SUPPLY BY
STIMULATING ENERGY PRODUCTION
AND BY SUBSIDIZING AND
SUPPORTING OUR ENERGY TRANSITION
TO RENEWABLES.
SO LESS DEMAND, MORE SUPPLY AND
DIRECT BETTER BARGAINING FOR
LOWER PRICES, THOSE ARE THE
THINGS THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
REDUCING INFLATION.
>> JUST TO GO BACK
HISTORICALLY -- AND THANK YOU
FOR ROLE-PLAYING THERE WITH
ME -- I IMAGINE THAT WAS
SOMETHING ALONG THE LINES OF
WHAT A CONVERSATION WITH A
SENATOR LIKE JOE MANCHIN WHO IS
CONCERNED ABOUT INFLATION MIGHT
ABOUT LIKE.
WHEN THE $1.9 TRILLION STIMULUS
BILL FIRST CAME UP IN THE
BEGINNING OF BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION YOU CALLED THAT
HISTORICALLY IRRESPONSIBLE.
I THINK THAT WAS THE PHRASE THAT
YOU USED THERE.
YOU SEE THIS AS VASTLY DIFFERENT
THAN THAT.
>> I DO.
AND THERE IS A VERY GOOD REASON
FOR IT.
THE $1.9 TRILLION BILL WAS
UNPAID FOR, THIS BILL IS MORE
THAN PAID FOR.
I THINK IF YOU USE REALISTIC
REVENUE ESTIMATES AND YOU ASSUME
THAT THE HUGE PROGRESS ON TAX
COMPLIANCE, ON COLLECTING THE
MONEY THAT'S OWED THAT NOW
ESCAPES TAXATION, TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WORTH OF IT, IF YOU USE
REALISTIC REVENUE ESTIMATES I
THINK YOU'RE RAISING MORE THAN
$2 IN REVENUE FOR EVERY DOLLAR
THAT YOU SPEND.
IN THAT ORIGINAL BILL THAT I
CRITICIZED YOU WERE RAISING NO
DOLLARS OF REVENUE FOR EVERY
DOLLAR YOU SPENT AND YOU WERE
SPENDING A VAST SUM OF REVENUE,
CLOSE TO $2 TRILLION, AND YOU
WERE SPENDING IT ALL IN ONE
YEAR.
HERE WE'RE SPENDING IT OVER MANY
YEARS AND WE'RE RAISING FAR MORE
REVENUE.
>> JUST SO PUT A FINE POINT ON T
YOU SEE THIS -- THEY ARE
ADVERTISING THIS AS FIGHTING
INFLATION.
YOU SEE THIS BILL AS FIGHTING
INFLATION?
>> THIS BILL IS FIGHTING
INFLATION AND IT'S GOT A WHOLE
SET OF COLLATERAL BENEFITS AS
WELL, BUT IT'S FAIR TO CALL IT
THE INFLATION REDUCTION ACT
BECAUSE IT'S DIRECTLY FIGHTING
THE RATE OF INFLATION.
>> THERE ARE SOME DEMOCRATIC
SENATORS FROM NORTHEASTERN
STATES WHO ARE DISAPPOINTED THAT
THERE AREN'T THE ISSUES WITH
STATE AND LOCAL TAXES.
THEY WANT DEDUCTIONS FOR STATE
AND LOCAL TAXES IN THIS BILL.
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO THEM IF
THEY WERE TO THREATEN TO HOLD
THIS BILL UP TO GET THAT BACK
IN?
>> I WOULD SAY WE'VE GOT ENOUGH
HOSTAGE TAKING IN THIS WORLD AND
WE HAVE ENOUGH HOSTAGE TAKING IN
THIS SENATE AND THEY WOULD BE
HOSTAGE TAKING AMERICA'S
PROSPERITY AND MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES' CHANCE OF NOT PAYING
HIGHER PRICES WITH INFLATION IF
THEY WERE TO INTERFERE WITH THIS
BILL.
LOOK, I'VE BEEN VERY LUCKY IN
LIFE AND I'M A HIGH-INCOME
TAXPAYER AND IT WOULD REDUCE MY
TAXES A WHOLE BUNCH IF THEY PUT
BACK DEDUCTIBILITY, BUT THAT
DOESN'T MAKE IT THE RIGHT OR THE
FAIR THING TO DO.
ONLY 20% OF PEOPLE IN OUR
COUNTRY EVEN TAKE ITEMIZED
DEDUCTIONS, SO THAT'S A BILL
THAT IS -- THAT'S A MEASURE THAT
IS TARGETED TOWARDS THOSE WITH
THE HIGHEST INCOMES AND THEY ARE
NOT THE PEOPLE WHO NEED MOST
SUPPORT IN OUR SOCIETY RIGHT
NOW.
SO I UNDERSTAND HOW THEY FEEL, I
UNDERSTAND THE ARGUMENT,
PERSONALLY IT WOULD MEAN A LOT
TO ME IF THEY DID IT, BUT IF YOU
LOOK AT IT FROM A POINT OF VIEW
OF THE WHOLE COUNTRY I THINK
IT'S JUST NOT THE RIGHT THING TO
DO.
>> WE ARE IN THE NEXT HOUR AND
17 MINUTES GOING TO HEAR ABOUT
GDP, ABOUT WHAT THE ECONOMY DID
IN THE LAST QUARTER.
THIS PREDICTION THAT I'M GOING
TO ASK YOU TO GIVE IT WON'T
STAND FOR VERY LONG BECAUSE
WE'RE GOING TO FIND OUT THE NEWS
IN AN HOUR BUT WHAT DO YOU
EXPECT WILL HAPPEN?
DO YOU THINK THE ECONOMY GREW OR
SHRANK LAST QUARTER?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
IT WILL BE ON ONE SIDE OR THE
OTHER SIDE OF ZERO, BUT IF YOU
LOOK AT A BROADER SUITE OF
INDICATORS, WHICH IS WHAT
SERIOUS ECONOMISTS DO, THEY
DON'T JUST LOOK AT ONE -- ONE
STATISTIC, I THINK IT'S PRETTY
CLEAR THAT AS OF RIGHT NOW THE
ECONOMY HAS BEEN GROWING, I
THINK IT'S PRETTY CLEAR THAT
THINGS ARE IN SOME JEOPARDY FOR
THE MEDIUM TERM, BUT RIGHT NOW,
HOWEVER THIS PARTICULAR NUMBER
TURNS OUT, YOU DON'T HAVE AN
ECONOMY THAT'S CURRENTLY IN
RECESSION THAT'S CREATING
350,000 JOBS A MONTH, YOU DON'T
HAVE AN ECONOMY THAT'S CURRENTLY
IN RECESSION WHERE YOU HAVE THE
KIND OF CONSUMER SPENDING
FIGURES THAT WE'VE BEEN SEEING.
I DO THINK BECAUSE OF A WHOLE
COMBINATION OF FACTORS AND,
FRANKLY, MOSTLY BECAUSE WE NEED
TO COOL OFF AN ECONOMY THAT GOT
ITSELF OVERSTIMULATED BY POLICY,
I DO FEAR THAT A RECESSION
SOMETIME IN THE NEXT YEAR OR TWO
IS VERY LIKELY, BUT I THINK WE
TOOK A USEFUL STEP IN GIVING THE
FED A LITTLE MORE RUNNING ROOM
WITH THE LEGISLATION THAT
SENATORS SCHUMER AND MANCHIN
HAVE AGREED ON IF THAT
LEGISLATION CAN PASS AS
EXPEDITIOUSLY AS POSSIBLE.
>> LARRY SUMMERS, YOU'VE BEEN
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF IT.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THIS
MORNING.
THANK YOU.
>> GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.